325 proposals for the eu of tomorrow
have been adopted in an unprecedented
exercise in european democracy
the proposals from the final plenary
meeting of the conference on the future
of europe are based on the priorities
and recommendations of european citizens
ideas were submitted online debated at
grassroots events in citizens panels of
the parliament in strasbourg and across
europe and in conference
plenaries there is in fact no opposition
between or no contradiction between
representative democracy and
participatory democracy i don't believe
anymore in a democracy that is only
an election every five years without
involvement of the citizens
this weekend participants of the
conference plenary met in strasbourg to
adopt 325 proposals across nine themes
ranging from health to the economy
migration to climate change
there is a huge consensus in the main
pillars of the conclusions and that we
are really resoluted to
put forward and to implement your
recommendations that by the way after
this dialogue are also our
recommendations
some of the more ambitious proposals
like ending country's veto powers in the
council would require treaty changes
a broad majority of parliament's
delegation supported the proposals but
consensus did not mean unanimity
it is difficult for the ecr group to
endorse these recommendations
and it should be clear that the position
of the european parliament is not
unanimous
citizens were at the heart of the
process determined to ensure their
voices would be heard
what will happen next how will these
draft recommendations
that we have
adopted this morning how will they be
taken forward they cannot be allowed
gather dust in some report on a shell
the final report will be presented to
the presidents of the eu institutions at
the closing ceremony in strasbourg on
europe day on the 9th of may
[Music]